the state of Arkansas
continues to waste the time and
resources of the people in the state Now
by restricting School bathroom use by
transgender people under the leadership
if you can call it that of Republican
Governor Sarah Huckabee Sanders they
have banned CRT from schools which
wasn't being taught in schools and they
are generally wasting a ton of time and
now the news is yes indeed Governor
Sarah Huckabee Sanders signed a new law
prohibiting trans people at public
schools from using the restroom of their
choice this would make Arkansas the
fourth place to put such restrictions on
public schools and it requires that
those that individuals use the bathroom
that match I believe the wording they're
using is their birth sex
Alabama Oklahoma and Tennessee have
filed similar restrictions although
lawsuits have been filed and this is
something that is growing and growing
and growing here's where I want to focus
today on this issue it's really
important to talk about the absurdity of
the bathroom issue there is simply no
evidence that trans people in public
bathrooms pose a threat to the safety of
others whether we're talking about kids
adults in schools out at restaurants in
malls or whatever the case may be one of
the big arguments really the biggest
argument that the right makes is that if
anybody can just use whatever bathroom
they want based on their alleged their
stated gender identity
it opens the door to stalking and sexual
assault and pedophilia and all sorts of
different things there is absolutely no
evidence that that is the case and in
fact when you look at the data there are
widespread studies about this Studies
have shown that trans people are way
more likely to be the victims of
violence and the victims of harassment
in public restrooms than they are to be
the perpetrators there's a 2013 study
from UCLA School of Law it finds 70
percent of trans respondents were
verbally harassed or assaulted or
mistreated in public restrooms a 2016
report by the Human Rights Campaign
found that 59 percent of trans people
avoided using public restrooms in the
preceding year because they were afraid
of those negative experiences and
there's a 2018 study from the AAP the
American Academy of Pediatrics which
finds trans people and gender
non-conforming youth are more likely to
experience verbal and physical abuse in
school restrooms on the other side of
this there is absolutely no study that
finds that when you look at incidents of
harassment sexual assault Etc in public
bathrooms that trans people are over
represented relative to their population
there is just no data that can support
that cause
and then there's the last aspect to this
if your concern is sexual assault or
harassment or whatever the case may be
it is already illegal
it does your gender identity doesn't
matter your genitalia doesn't matter it
is already illegal to engage in sexual
assault or harassment or stalking or
photography or whatever the case may be
in public restrooms doesn't matter which
bathroom you're in the gender identity
of the individuals involved also doesn't
matter and the law is applied equally
whether you are cisgender or transgender
the law is already there and there is no
evidence that trans people are more
likely to commit
sexual assault or harassment than
cisgender people so the entire framework
here is a moral panic and fear framework
as is often the case with right Wingers
they don't have the facts on their side
because the facts aren't on their side
and so it's based on fear and the idea
quite frankly the idea that they want to
tell you is that Hulk Hogan is going to
put on a wig go into a public bathroom
and harass little girls that's the idea
the the image that these folks want you
to believe it's not happening there is
no data that backs this up as an actual
danger and Sarah Huckabee Sanders just
continues wasting time on this complete
and utter nonsense
one of our sponsors today is blue chew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping